hi everyone in this video I'll talk
about Golgi apparatus and I'll take you
through the structures to the functions
of Kogi apparatus if you watched my
other videos you know that the
endoplasmic reticulum of a cell is just
like a factory where the proteins are
formed proteins are folded they are
packaged and their quality checked for
distributing to the other sides of the
cell now this factory is associated with
a warehouse and that warehouse is
actually the Golgi apparatus
so clearly the Golgi apparatus could be
understood as a warehouse of a cell
where several products are packaged
sorted out for delivery to distant
locations inside the cell or may be
secreted outside the cell now just like
a warehouse where trucks are taking the
parcels and the products for delivery
into several part of the city from Golgi
apparatus there are specific vesicles
going either towards out of the cell for
security secretary products maybe some
of the vesicles are going towards
specific organelles like lysosome
some of them might go to mitochondrion
like different other locations locations
inside the cell now this process is well
coordinated by several intermediate
players and for Golgi as well this
process is well coordinated now imagine
that this is the endoplasmic reticulum
there are several vesicles which are
budding off the endoplasmic reticulum is
fusing with a sis ecology where there
are intra Golgi transport and the
products are modified labeled and ready
to delivery to several locations inside
the cell or outside of the cell we would
look at how this sorting process works
in
the Gaulke how the transport is
selectively delivering the product
inside the several locations inside the
cell or maybe outside the cell and also
we have to understand this process of
sorting and delivery that is taken care
of by Golgi is pretty complicated
imagine selective receptors that need to
be delivered to the apical surface or
some ion channels or or some protein
molecules that has to be delivered into
the basal surface of the cell so how
does Golgi ensures that the proteins
that need to be displayed on the apical
surface are selectively delivered to the
apical surface not the basal surface and
vice versa so this kind of stringent
decision and stringent sorting kind of
activity happens in the goalie and that
is why GOG is such an important
structure now if we imagine Gogi as a
post office of a cell then you can
understand all the parcels or order
letters that need to be distributed to
several locations inside the city that
has to be addressed tagged right so the
proteins inside the Gogi also need to be
tagged with a unique marker and the tag
turns out to be in linked glycosylation
tag glycosylation simply means attaching
sugar to something now here a complex
sugar or oligosaccharide is attached to
the newly synthesized protein and this
at this attachment of the tag starts in
the ER and this tag is work like a
address barcode which would help the
sorting machine machinery or the
vesicles to deliver it into specific
locations let a part of this video we'll
take a specific example to look at how
lysosomal hydrolyzed enzymes are
selectively delivered to the lysosome
and not any other locations inside the
cell now first we should ask that where
does this glycosylation taking place it
turns out glycosylation starts in
endoplasmic reticulum but quite a lot of
part is happening in the Golgi networks
in the Golgi networks there's there are
basic functions which ensures that
several manners manners residues are
chopped off from these basic tag there
are other enzymes which ensures several
in acetyl glucosamine is added to this
tag several other transferase enzyme
transfers galactose silac acid etcetera
in the trans-golgi network now this
specific modification ensures which
protein is going to be delivered to
which location we take an example of
delivery of hydrolyzed enzyme into the
lysosome now hydrolyzed enzyme has the
basic tag one modifier enzyme known as
phosphor transferase
attached is a phosphate residue on the
mannose and this mannose 6-phosphate
modification is going to be recognized
by mannose 6-phosphate receptor now
mannose-6-phosphate receptors quickly
what like a sorting signal they form
they allow to bind the adapter protein
along with it and they attract
Triskelion molecules which would
ultimately form a clapeyron coat and
allow the clattering coated vesicles
to burn out from the trans-golgi network
later using specialized molecule motors
which are just like trucks
these cargoes would be delivered to
specific locations inside the lysosome
now once they are reaching the lysosome
they're going to fuse with the lysosomal
membrane inside the lysosome there the
pH is different because lysosome also
has proton pumps that always pumping in
proton that making the lysosomal inside
interior to be a lot more acidic in this
acidic environment the interaction
between the mannose-6-phosphate receptor
and the mannose 6-phosphate signal is
broken there are other components which
would chop off this mannose-6-phosphate
signal such that the enzyme that reached
the lysosome cannot go back once it is
done then the empty trucks that means
the vesicle is going to be carried back
and it might fuse with the Kogi with the
help of a retrograde transport that is
how specific proteins or specific
enzymes are delivered to specific
locations of the cells using the help of
specialized sorting mechanism inside the
Golgi apparatus and also this is very
important in terms of proper segregation
of the products improper transport of
this lysosomal hydrolase might cause
diseases like lysosomal storage
disorders which could be sometimes
detrimental so that is why Golgi
apparatus is so important so in this
video we looked at all the apparatus
from a structure to the functional point
of view if you liked this video give it
a quick thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you